hello and welcome to looker and bigquery
Enterprise digital transformation at
SunRun I'm Joel McKelvey with the looker
team and joining me is Harish Rawat's
Andrea from SunRun we're going to be
talking about modernizing your data
infrastructure and modernizing your
analytics together to drive better
business outcomes and to accelerate
digital transformation in your
organization now this is particularly
important now because we know that data
driven our insight driven businesses are
far more likely to succeed during a time
of disruption like the one we're seeing
now they're going to be more profitable
have higher customer satisfaction and
customer retention and they're going to
be able to drive better and more
efficient operations etc so it's really
key that we successful with data so then
why are not why are more companies not
successful with data and I think it
comes down to with all the businesses
I've spoken with this concern of
balancing the maintenance keeping the
lights on using the systems that exist
already with the need to innovate and
update and and build new systems or
better systems going forward and it
comes down to a rapidly increasing
supply of the three V's of volume
variety and velocity of data but also an
incredible demand for data and demand
for insights in the business and keeping
up with the two of those particularly
when you're maintaining legacy systems
can be a real challenge good news is
that there's hope with modern technology
data lakes and data warehouses have
effectively become a single entity that
is to say the massively parallel
processing cloud-based database like
bigquery can be both a data Lake and a
data warehouse so you no longer need
staging database an analytic database
and maybe a data Mart all that data can
be consolidated in a single location
which gives you a really nice source of
truth for the business simplifying data
pipelines making an analytics much more
real-time and then when you take a
modern analytic system like looker and
you connect it to one of these modern
data warehouses suddenly you've got data
governance it's scale data becomes very
very accessible you free up your data
team to do more and to focus more on
that innovation and you can
operationalize data in new and very
exciting ways to drive those outcomes
you need what we call these new ways of
using data is data experiences certainly
all the organizations I work with are
looking at modernizing business
intelligence getting better dashboards
and reporting making that simpler making
that easier but there are new ways to
use data when you're not spending all of
your time on the infrastructure and
analytics maintenance and these new ways
include putting Analects directly in the
CRM or a chat application that your
teams might be using inserting insights
directly into people's workflows right
where and when they need them most to
make better decisions not just
large-scale decisions in the
organization but even micro scale
decisions say on a factory production
line or something along those lines so
making data so operationalize that the
people consume it may not even know that
they're what they're seeing is analytics
outcome and you can even build custom
applications or use data in really new
interesting and innovative ways to
monetize data or drive those outcomes
you're looking for so one organizations
that spend very successful driving
positive business outcomes with data is
SunRun led by Harish ramachandraiah
who's with me today and he's gonna talk
a little bit about his transition from
an older infrastructure to where he is
today some of the pitfalls and benefits
he's seen doing that and I think you'll
be really excited to hear what he has to
say so with that I'm gonna hand over to
Harish Harish
take it away thank you Joe
Thanks so so with that said just a quick
background about shunran SunRun has been
is in being in the solar industry number
one residential solar company its
pioneered in the solar industry for
quite some time now and since then it is
offered a number of products out there
and the latest being battery as a
service as well as the storage options
in just to keep it simple what we do is
essentially have the customers of the
consumer buy electricity from at a
discounted price than what the entities
would otherwise offer in but what we
offer is a clean energy environmental
friendly eco friendly options and so so
that's our mission and if you look at
our mission is to ensure that we run the
planet by the Sun right so with that
said you know you could envision any of
your company in similar profile to the
company where you've been associated you
may be in the crossroads of a bi
transformation and someone was no
different couple of years back so you
could imagine in most of the companies
out there either have a monolithic
transactional system either an SAT or an
Oracle environment and and then number
of other platforms in terms of marketing
or sales platforms and counter to that
you have bi applications where you
essentially have locked into a license
or an infrastructure or a support cost
and and skill sets and so on so forth
and people no different than that along
with that I think some of the business
questions what we were trying to address
in terms of the transformation was how
do I I justify the ROI or or how do I do
the transformation yet without doing the
disruption in the existing side of the
business and within the engineering team
we were in the dilemma trying to figure
out that is it as simple as you know
lift and shift of your data sets or the
schemas from one environment to the
other environment or you know porting
these pipelines from one to the other
ecosystem in and are you really going to
solve the problem right and certainly
not right I mean you want to take
advantage of the newer platforms with
the better architecture and so and so
forth so how do we solve that right so
so we've embarked on a journey right you
know two to three years back in trying
to figure out how do we go about in
transforming some of these problems and
some of the critical ones I have noted
here but but I'm sure most of you can
relate to this as well as it resonates
among you is time to market rightful
from a business standpoint it was very
very critical for us to work in close
proximity with the business to be able
to turn around some of their analytical
needs and and in in a very short
duration and given the situation right
the expectations was to build deploy and
be able to execute some of these
products in a very short duration and
given that we were operating in a
capital and labor intensive market it
was very critical for us to be able to
turn around some of these things also
the the more popular one about single
source of truth you know given the
number of integration points we have the
each of the business units would have
their own set of single source of truth
or their own versions of it and and then
the timings of it which would never
align and they would never come to an
agreement and so we wanted to take this
opportunity to ensure that some of those
business rules are encapsulated both of
the physical layer as well as the
logical layer for the scene exactly
execs to come into the forum and be able
to align you know based on the KPI of
the same set of metrics what they would
they have agreed upon and so it was very
prudent for us to ensure that that
single source of truth is is in good
shape and in in further - that is the
infrastructure right and for those of us
who have coming from the legacy platform
or the on-premise side of it you know
having managed services was you know the
best thing to have or we loved it
considering that you know you're looking
at the pipelines you're looking at the
infrastructure from a data warehousing
standpoint ingest data sets a petabyte
scale as well as from a reporting
standpoint where you overnight have
certain expectations to scale up the
number of users and so and so forth and
we certainly were we didn't want to be
in the business of capacity planning
right and so that was very important for
us to be able to overnight Auto scale
some of these expectations the other
thing was
in terms of the cost aspects of it and
for us it certainly mattered to figure
out what are the kind of transaction saw
these projects are undertaking in what
are the costs involved in it are we
locked and is it flexible enough can we
predict some of these cost aspects of it
so that tomorrow if the business needs
to do additional investment they have
full transparency about what what is it
is costing us and and and in that that
level of visibility certainly would be
helping us and and finally the most
important one is certainly security in
the compliance side of it which is we
handle quite a bit of it there is still
a lot to go there in terms of the DLP in
terms of PII and in the next subsequent
quarters we certainly plan to address
that so with that said I would not go
into the legacy aspects of it but more
on the current infrastructure of the
architecture what we have in place at
SunRun right so if you look at this you
looking from left to right in
essentially you have a combination of
various platform on cloud on-premise as
well as you know formats of these data
sets in terms of CSV to API to JSON all
kinds of format at the same time you're
looking at the data coming from some of
these financial systems like Oracle we
have two ERP environments and work based
production data sets coming from solar
panels and so on so forth in some of
these data sets certainly have highly
tanked time sensitive from from an
investor relationship or the Wall Street
information as well as work day for
example as as number of footprints in
terms of productivity and as well as you
know traditional reporting and so on and
so forth so as these data makes its way
into the target environment which is
cloud storage where we retain the raw
form of it we use number of components
or variations of this in terms of data
proc there are flow and then informatica
predominantly place in terms of doing
the pipeline and so the raw form which
arrives at the cloud storage is
is almost like Noddy trail coming out of
the source system right you could trace
back any of these transaction
information but subsequent to that is
where we kind of take a two-step
approach in terms the data and then
subsequently a derive table between the
two steps what we essentially do is to
ensure that the change data capture gets
handled in a very seamless manner right
and in stage one and then subsequently
if there are any heavy transformation of
the business rules we incorporated in
the subsequent step which is probably
close to twenty plus none of those
elements get transformed but by and
large we take advantage of this stating
itself from a reporting standpoint and
so between the two we ensure that you
know we are good to go from a reporting
standpoint right from a physical layer
and start building the logical layer and
in along the way we also ensure that we
make the best practice from a bigquery
standpoint whether it's in in terms of
foundation making sure that it is cost
effective as well as establishing
certain joints because just in the
nature of bigquery in terms of this
being a distributed system we want to
make sure it makes really sense where it
needs join if not we try to take
advantage of the platform and then we
have certain homegrown open source
orchestration engine and then we have
scheduler from an airflow and other
monitoring tools you know in order to
maintain manage these pipelines and in
subsequently it makes its way from a
consumer standpoint where we have looker
which which is from prominent reporting
to not just from a visualization and
report aspects but but also we take
advantage of it in more like a data as a
service and that's something which we
are in full thrust as we speak besides
looker where I think close to seventy
percent of the execs rely on some of
these two cooling aspects coming over
the looker
there are other consumers like there are
some cases where Google makes use of it
for quick turnarounds and pocs and so on
so forth the AI and MO people again tap
into the same
sets and for them it's a curator
datasets it is transformed there's
nothing much they need to do versus
focus on modeling and take full
advantage of what bigquery can provide
them from an animal standpoint and then
the other consumers are your and a plan
or some of the planning systems as well
as we also provide the integration hub
so so that that's how the current
structure but but if you really look at
there a number of pipes or the arrow
marks which essentially they're they're
equally prone for certain failures and
so we ensure that these are well managed
monitor and taken care and to give you a
quick preview of the pipelines the data
warehouse or this quickly go over that
so as you as I pointed out in terms of
the double-click right and then any
failure in these pipelines can cost a
wrong decision downstream so we want to
make sure that it is well managed and
and so the footprint is close to around
700 or pipelines as we speak and it is
growing incremental a almost every month
the other aspects and this is the type
of transactions we handle it's not just
if volume said of it it's more to do
with the complexity across the ways data
sources as well as correlations of these
data sets in order to me write a good
data story for some of the business
units you're talking of integrations
between financial systems Salesforce
systems as well as HR and so on so forth
to do some complex analysis from a cycle
time from conversion analysis as well as
the reporting coming out of the tax SEM
and in financial systems besides that we
we started at the cadence of 24 hours in
terms of scheduling these data sets but
that's got reduced almost on all
everyday and so we run these jobs at a
very high frequency on most of the
environments including ERP then just to
double-click on the bigquery again
this is more to talk about how we manage
these slot allocations from a resource
standpoint essentially we have three
segments here the the ETL or in our case
we manage the e-elt process looker from
a reporting standpoint and then the back
end users who tap into the bigquery
these are the three segments but we also
have the ability to prioritize in our
case we we have look at as the most
prominent in user community to take
advantage of it and then the other slots
come into picture so that that's the
brief approach and so far we haven't had
any challenges in terms of resource
allocation and and if you have to scale
up it's a matter of few minutes you can
certainly scale it even further so so
that that's the aspects from a data
warehousing standpoint and then finally
the reporting looker again has come a
long way for us in so as I said it is
not just reporting in terms of
visualization aspects we've taken it in
terms of the hub and spoke models within
the Luca community where we not only
enable the business users to do
self-service reports not just candor
building those reports but but also if
you really look at the power users we
extend our capacity of development
effort along with the business community
in terms of enabling the the data models
as well as exploring it and and
establishing certain metrics which you
know the central engineering team may or
may not necessarily address but instead
we have a opportunity to extend those
spoke models into the business community
so overall you know that that has
accelerated not only the development
cycle but also to bring in some of the
SME knowledge which the business units
can bring in and turn around certain
pocs integrate some of their data sets
which we probably don't have visibility
and have a wider footprint and have a
protocol to ensure besides some of the
automation in terms of testing these
data sets see sed process and so on so
forth
so that's on the on the the
on the reporting side and just to take
it for blur I just wanted to highlight
one of the case studies I know there are
a lot of information about social media
analytics in terms of sales conversions
of marketing channels analysis out there
and and so we thought of sharing some of
the case studies from an Oracle
financial standpoint where we were
having pre-built ETL or a pipeline as
well as physical data model star schemas
as well as a report coming out of the
box in something which we we engineered
it within the Google platform to ensure
that some of these data sets you know
there are hundreds of these pipelines
which are fairly complex in nature as I
said it's not just a volume it is the
complexity in integrating various data
sets and in this example the financials
in terms of general ledger accounts
receivables tables we we take advantage
of it in order to arrive at the profit
and loss statements and and and it has
been in jail
engineering drama SunRun the other
aspects which you can even take it
further is you could easily integrate
this into demand planning system along
with it as well as a financial planning
system and you know there are other
aspects if you are running a market
marketing campaign during a certain
period you could snapshot those
information real time and be able to see
if these are having an impact by your
your campaigns or they're having impact
from adorable aspects in terms of
conversions and look at it within the
particular window we haven't certainly
done it but since we've taken care of
the financial system it's easily
imaginable to integrate some of these
data sets and it is we have converted
the entire financial systems as well as
some of the other supply chains or so
forth on the Oracle financials and you
can easily relate this to an HCP
environment where you're having
controlling and profitability or a low
cockpits MLS and so on so forth so with
that said I just wanted to quickly go or
the certain monitoring aspects on each
of those environments we have the
ability to manage monitor the GCP
environment the looker as well as no
doubt the station and then these are the
reports which we use out of the lookup
to ensure that there is consistency in
the data loops if there are any failures
or any exceptions alerts we have
automation done in place to handle on a
nightly basis and not necessarily lose
sleep over it and there's more to go but
but this is something which we handled
on a day to day basis and then one quick
question on areas in terms of
establishing that confidence within the
business community was pretty critical
for us and so we put a lot of things in
place to a process in place to ensure
that the business or looking at the very
authoritative data and the slides
essentially speaks about you know how
the we consolation happens between the
source system and the target environment
in this case the production if you
notice is is in a fairly good shape we
we run this process along with the data
loads to ensure that the number of
transaction or any impacts on the
metadata structures or any elements
being introduced is reconciling between
source and the targets and as you can
see the QA certainly are off sync and
essentially because there are no
projects live projects in the current
state as well as on the day of
environments where work is in progress
so these are some of the things which
helps establish those confidence within
the business units to take it further
and just to give it just about the
journey with where we started you know
we we started something like a phase
zero where we undertook our POC and it
was certainly not a lift and shift
engage with number of partners and then
embarked on a full-scale development
effort and we took approximately year
and a half to travel 80 to 90 percent of
the footprint from or legacy platform
into the cloud and we basically
undertook certain user community which
would gain more mileage and took
advantage of the platform and certainly
build those confidence and and then it
was kind of wildfire at someone to to
enable some of the business units and
and that came extremely
and II and there was a lot of
acknowledgement in shunran and certainly
today most of the code reporting aspects
comes out of DCP and lucre and we
wrapped up our project 100% into the
cloud now it's been a couple of quarter
since we've gone like and currently we
are heading north towards the ML and
yeah initiatives taking advantage of
what the bigger bigquery platform can
provide us in addition to the analogies
and just a final thought as the takeaway
does this is the final point what what
we got out of our overall initiative was
you know how could we add business value
back into and and this is this
particular slide if you really notice
our legacy infrastructure or the legacy
environment in the application in terms
of the dev site of what it would
undertake was essentially we reduced
significantly in terms of your
infrastructure as well as data modeling
aspects and the reporting enablement and
we've reduced in some of the areas close
to 70% 80% in terms of life cycle and
certainly those are the business
benefits which we can give it back and
and and it has certainly increased our
footprint in there it's been an
extremely successful run at some run and
both with great partnership but look
around big query we were able to achieve
this in a very short duration I just
wanted to thank my team bi team at Sam
run and certainly my boss Lorraine for
providing the support he heads the
engineering team and but for him we
wouldn't have been here and so thank you
all and I hope you have some takeaway
from these initiatives both from look
current that bigquery standpoint and I
will be suddenly here to field any
questions and answers thank you